よろしくお願いします
エーワンメーソタンというところですけど
このように私が聞いたというふうに始まりますね
それは伝統的な日本語になると
この何でしたっけ？私に日本語のコピーくださいませんか？十分です
今ないんです  時々言葉が分からなくなったところですね
こちらはこのように私は聞いたという言葉ですね
で だいたいそれは経典の決まり文句で
でお釈迦様が亡くなってからこの経典全部まとめたんですね
亡くなって 三ヶ月間経ったところで
アーナンダ尊者という阿羅漢がいて
ほとんど覚えていらっしゃいましたからね
すごい記憶 記憶力のすごい方で
ですから この私はこのように聞きましたと
お釈迦様からこのように聞きましたという報告をして
一応アーナンダ尊者がこのお釈迦様がおっしゃったことの出来事も入れて
内容を語るんです で この経典でお釈迦様の言葉は一応少ないと思いますけど
ちょっとストーリーが入ってますからね
そこでエーカンサミャンバガワクルースチャーリカンチャラマーノ
インドのクルという国でお釈迦様がこの旅に出かけたんですね
遊行されてという このチャーリカン
旅と言っても これはどういう意味かというと
この 三ヶ月間 お釈迦様一か所に泊まっているんです
雨期というか この雨季の時
インドの雨季っていうのは大変きついもので
毎日すごい豪雨なんですね
それで宗教の方々は その時は歩いてはいけませんと決めていたんです
仏教だけではないんです
で 裸足で歩くでしょうし
ですからいっぱいこの虫とかね
地面から出てくるんですね
アスファルト道路はなかったんだから
ですから それも虫やらね
踏んで歩くのはどういうことかと
ですから どこかに泊まってくださいということになるんです
その習慣でお釈迦様もこの 三ヶ月間は一か所に泊まっていらっしゃって
雨季が終わった途端 次の雨季まで歩くんです
いろんなところに 一か所にはいないんですね
歩いては説法する 歩いては説法する
そこでこのクルという国に行ったんですね
比丘たちと一緒に そこでイエナトゥッレコッティターナンナームクルーナニガモタダワサリ
クル国のこのトゥッレコッティタという大きな町がありまして
そこに泊まりました で
アッソーソンコトゥッレコッティタブラフミナガハペティカ
このトゥッレコッティというこの国の村のバラモンたちやら
サイケの人々ですね その人々にこの話が流れて行ったんですね
お釈迦様が自分の村に来ましたと
ニガマという村ですから
これはものすごい大きな村なんですね
小さな村たくさん集めたところで
この村で大きな村出来上がっちゃうんですね
それをニガマと呼んで
パーリ語で  [咳]で それでまあどういうふうにお釈迦様のことを言われた
聞かれたんですかというと
サマノカルボゴーテモ
サマノゴートモっていうのお釈迦様の名前
ゴートマっていうのは名前でサマノっていうのは出家しているんだから
そのサマノと呼ばれているんですね
このサッキャプット サカ族の人でサッキャクラパッバジット
サカ族から出てきて出家したんだと
このサッキャプットサッキャクラパッバジットっていうのは大変褒め言葉で
お釈迦様の家族のことなんですね
で サカというシャーキヤってサンスクリット語で呼んで
その民族の一人なんですね
このシャーキヤ民族が数少なかったんだけども
大変もう一番偉い 偉いというか
一番上のインドでバラモンカーストの人々よりも一番上のカーストの人々だと
当時で尊敬されていたんですね
ですから 釈族の人やということは
まあ一つの敬語というか
尊敬の言葉なんです インドにあった一番最高なカーストくらいの人ですよという意味で
パッバジットクルースチャーリカンチャルマーノ
クルーという国で旅に出ているんだと
たくさん比丘たちと一緒にそれでトゥルラこの国に来ているんだと
タンコーパナバガワンタンゴートマンエーワンカルヤーノキッティサッドアッブガと
お釈迦様に対してこのこのような噂が流れたんだと
噂っていうのは悪い言葉ですけど
カルヤーノキッティサッド
褒め言葉なんですね まあ広げていたんですね
これは今私も先にお経で教えた申し上げたこのイティピソウバガワーアラハンサマーサンブッドというところなんですね
ページの三行目からあるところ
そこら辺は大体誰でもテーラワーダ仏教の人々は覚えているところで
イティピソウバガワーその説明にいっちゃうと
もう何時間もかかっちゃうんです
で これお釈迦様はどういう人間でしたかということなんです
イティピソウバガワーアラハンサマーサンブッド
これはこのみんなの話題になった項目の名前だけなんです
ですからわからないんですよ
そのみんないろんなもう話題語ってるんですね
それは大体まとめちゃうと九つになる
その九つの項目だけまとめてみんな暗記しているんですね
ですから この釈尊がアラハン
アラハンであると いわゆるアラハンというのは日本語で阿羅漢ということなんですね
悟った人ですよと インドであれほど宗教あったんだけど
当時でぐらいの んですよ
でも誰一人も自分が悟りました
もう分かったぞというその一言葉言ってないんですね
まあこういう風に修行すれば悟りますよと頑張ってるんだよというふうに言うだけで
自分がこの完全たる境地に至ったと言ったもう一人がいたんですけど
彼がこのジャイナ教のニガンタという人なんですね
彼が十二年間苦行すればもう悟りますよと言って
日にち数えちゃったんですね
とにかく 本当に真面目に十二年間苦行してしまったんですね
それで私はもう十二年間ちょうど丸々苦行したんだから
もうケーリという完璧な人やということになって
もうそうなっただけなんですね
それでお釈迦様は彼が本当はそうではないということをちょっと間接的に仰ってはいるんですね
彼が悪い人だと言ってないんだけど
もう十二年間真面目に苦行した人は決して悪い人ではないんだからね
彼が言うのは 自分が完全な人になったんだから
過去も現在も未来も何だかんでもすぐわかるんだと
丸い鏡にいつでも全てのものを映してるんだから
上であろうが下であろうか
後ろだろうが前であろうかね
そのより自分の心に 起きていても寝ていても
全てのものがもう知ってるんだと
お釈迦様それをからかっちゃうんですよ
だからもうすごい気をつけて
お釈迦様いる年上なんです
ですから もうなんであんなことを言うんでしょうかという言葉ではなくて
まあでもなんでニガンタさんがね
町に道に迷いますかね
旅に出かける時とかね
なんで時々人にどこかの村に行きたいんだけど
どう行けばいいんでしょうかと道なんか聞くんでしょうかとかね
というふうな一言葉でちょっとからかってくるんですね
ですから まあそれで彼の予言やいろいろなものそれはちょっと違いますよと言ったところもありますけどね
そういうことで この過去現在未来
いつでもいっぺんに 常に寝ていても知ってるんだということにお釈迦様がちょっと批判しました
お釈迦様は言うのはそれはありえないんだと
不可能ですよと という立場でしたから
ですから この完全に悟ったそうと言えば
お釈迦様だけ自分が悟り開いたんだと言ったんですね
ですから お釈迦様の話題になると
そのお釈迦様の言葉がやっぱり話題になるんですよ
あるところである王様が六人の偉大なる先生たちがいるのに
一人も阿羅漢になった
悟ったとは言ってないんだと
みんなあなたより年上ですよと
あんた若いんでしょうと
でもあんたよくもそういうことを言いますよと言った時もありますね
言ったらお釈迦様はそこを説明して
まあまあこういうことで
煩悩なくなったことが阿羅漢になることでだよと説明してあげるんですね
ですから 阿羅漢になったということ
阿羅漢になったということを悟ったという意味で
全ての煩悩なくなりましたと
心にかすかな汚れもないんだよという意味なんですね
それで阿羅漢でしょうと
それから次の言葉 サンマーサンブッド
サンマーサンブッダっていうのは
完全に悟り開いたということでブッダになりましたと
ブッダっていうのは智慧という意味なんですね
ですから 完全たる智慧を獲得しましたと
そこで完全たる智慧を獲得しましたという場合も
ブッダって何なのかって
また説明がいろいろみんなの話題になってくる
で テーラワーダ仏教ではサンマーサンブッダの解釈は
この悟ることは阿羅漢になることなんですね
ですから 誰でも自分で道を発見して悟れば
阿羅漢と言ってもよろしいし
ブッダと言ってもいいんです
でも 人間の能力の差があるんですね
能力の差っていうのは
この悟ったら全ての言葉が消えちゃうんですよ
頭から概念ももう人間の世界からもうもう離れているんですね
貪瞋痴という世界から
ですから この一般の人々と話したいという気持ちもないし
自分で何かみんなに教えてあげるぞと教えてあげなくちゃあかんぞという
そういう感情もないんですね
だから全くこの落ち着いている
このもう平らな心になってしまっちゃうんですね
そういう状態になったら
人と挨拶することだけでも苦痛なんですよ
だっていろいろもう何々さんですよとかね
思い浮かんでいかがでしょうかとか
社会的な状況を考えて頭を混乱させないとできないんですね
ですから 大体悟った人はそれっきり語らないんですね
一言葉も ですから インドでお釈迦様前にもいろいろ悟った人々がいただろうと仮定してみると
いても誰もわからない
語りませんだから だから悟った人にムニと言うんですね
お釈迦様のことを日本語でも釈迦牟尼仏陀とでも言うでしょうしね
ムニと言うんです ムニっていうのはもう亡者ですから
語らない人だと ですから
お釈迦様も本当はそういう状態でしたから
最初は語りたくなかったんですね
もうもういいと それで語りませんと思ったら
後でまた考え直して これはもう語らなきゃ人々はかわいそうだということで説法を始めたんですね
そこでどなたでも悟り開いたらもう無二になってしまって
語れない人間になってしまっちゃうと
そうすると人類の役に立ちませんね
ただお礼をして礼をして拝んで
それで終わっちゃうんですね
そこで語るためにはものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
また 人間の世界のことを考えて
人々はどのように生きているんですか？とか
またその一旦自分が立ち上がった泥の沼にまたもういじらなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそれにまたさらに能力必要なんですよ
才能が必要なんで お釈迦様にはものすごい言語の才能とかね
ものすごい勉強していたんだから
出家する前に天才でしたからね
もうインドのすべての宗教
学問 歴史 言語学 いろんなことを勉強してあったんですね
ですから 自分がこの勉強したノウハウ
テクニックを使って いろんな宗教の言葉いっぱい借りて
絶対語れないこの真理の道を語ってみせたんですね
だからお釈迦様が人間として得たこの才能ですよ
悟ってから得た才能じゃないんです
悟る前にもその才能はあったんです
そことこの悟りの智慧と合わせたら
もう抜群に仏教を語る能力が出てきたんですね
だからお釈迦様のことはサンマンサンブッダとと呼ぶようになったんですね
もう完全だよと 悟ってから無二になったわけじゃなくて
黙っていたわけじゃなくて
やっぱり我々の社会にまた戻ってきて
我々と一緒にご飯食べて
一緒に喧嘩もしながら
もうよく語ってくれましたと
弟子を育てて もう弟子を叱りながらしっかり弟子を育て
後の時代に仏教残るように全部整理までして
修行方法はきちんと作って
それから道徳もきちんと作っておいて
人間誰にでも悟られるような道を作っておいたんですね
そこはもう天才の中の天才にしかできない仕事なんです
ただ悟っただけでできません
そこで今でもいますよ
いろいろ もう仏教の方々は一生懸命真面目に修行して
いろいろ精神的な高いいろんな境地に至ってはいるんだけど
ただ黙っているだけで
誰も知らない どこかの結婚式やらね
あるいは村の祭りとかあったら
みんなと一緒に行ってご飯作るは
もう薪を持ってくる もう火を作ってご飯炊くはとかね
そういうことをして もうお手伝いしてそのまま帰っちゃうと誰も知りません
もう本当に心はすごい立派な方ですよと
もうなんとなくもう人格がよくできてる人っていうぐらいわかるだけでね
感情的ではないとかね
人々は何か喧嘩にでもなったらもうなんとかそこら辺でもうなんでもそうですね
まあそこでそこら辺で仲良くしましょうよとかね
そういうぐらいのことで
なかなか分からないんですね
ですから この お釈迦様の場合はやっぱりそういう悟りを開いて
それからこのよく人間で理解できるように語ったっていうことは大変なことで
ですから お釈迦様にサンマンサンブッダという言葉を使っているんですね
お釈迦様の弟子たちにはもう阿羅漢という言葉でもう終わってしまっちゃうんです
そこでお釈迦様が亡くなって
そういう分 時間経ったところで
いろんなもう仏教と関係ない人々はね
サンマンサンブッダからその人はすごく偉い状態に悟っていて
あんた方の悟りはそれほど偉くない
完璧じゃないという話になりましたけど
それはちょっとしたものをわからなかった人々の批判だけなんですね
本当の状態はこういう状態なんですね
もう言葉消えてしまって
もう何も言うことなくなっちゃいますからね
で 次にヴィッチャーチャラサンパンノという話題になったんですね
ヴィッチャーというのは知恵のこと
種類知恵知恵がありました
で チャラナというのは種に分けているこの道徳なんですね
で ですからヴィッチャーチャラナというのは
人間には知恵も必要し
道徳も必要なんですよ
例えば 頭がすごい抜群がいい人で
性格はもう最低だったら役に立たないんですよ
たとえ逆に性格は最高にいいんだけど
頭が全くだと言ったら
それまた役に立たないんですね
何かすかに悪いことをしないんだけど
に足すには何でしょうかと言ったってもわからないんだと
一応でまた役に立たないんですよ
だから世の中に必要な完璧な人間なんですね
学校の先生でも大学の先生でも立派ですけど
それだけで足りませんよ
人格も必要なんですよ
すごいリーダーとしてすごい人格も必要なんですね
学校の先生は子どもたちにもうビシビシと教えたりして
学校終わったら飲み屋さんでも飲んだくれてね
アル中になっちゃうといい先生ではないんですね
ですから このヴィッチャーチャラナというのは
やっぱり知恵と道徳 全部もうセットになっているんだよと
ところで 日本の社会に見ても
その問題しょっちゅうと見えるんですね
子どもたちはものすごい真面目に勉強して
すごい頭がいいんですけど
道徳的な方でもうすぐ欠けているんですね
それでいろんなもう親を殴ったり
どこかへ行って万引きしたりとかね
もう何とかしてしまっちゃって
もうかわいそうに人生が苦く悪くなってしまっちゃうんですね
だから勉強だけじゃないんで
その分人間としても道徳も育てなくちゃいけないんで
その場合はお釈迦様が素晴らしく
この知恵も完成して 道徳の人間としても生き方をすごい完成していたんだという話なんです
次にスガトという言葉なんですけど
スガトというのは俗的な日本語で言えばよくやりましたと
というぐらいの意味なんですね
ちゃんとした意味いっぱいありますよ
きちんと修行を完成したという意味と
またいろいろありますけど
時間なくなりますから
そこら辺置いておきます
あの 皆さんに配っている小さなテキストありますね
お経文句入っている そこで軽く意味書いていると思います
ローカビドゥという次の言葉
ローカっていうのは世界のこと
ビドゥっていうのはまあえっと
知っているんだということなんですね
世界全部知っている で
仏教で世界というのは生命のことなんです
宇宙のことじゃないんです
だから全ての生命のことは知り尽くしているという意味なんです
宇宙の場合はローカダートと呼んで
物理的な世界の場合は
ですからローカビドゥというのはもう生命のこと
人間だけじゃないんです
一切の生命ことを知り尽くしているということ
次にアヌッテロプリセダムサーリティという言葉なんですね
アヌッテロというのはこの上ないという意味で
プリセダムサーリティというのは人を指導することはよくできるんだと
導くことをできるんだと
これ大変な仕事なんですよ
たとえお母さんにしても
自分の子供をもう完全な大人として育てることはなかなか大変なんですよ
言うことは聞いてくれないんですよ
そこでお母さんたちもいろいろ工夫するんだけど
なかなかうまくいかないんですね
ですから 自分が産んだ子供だから
赤ちゃんの時からもう何から何まで知り尽くしているにも関わらず
その子を成長させる場合は大変苦労するんです
大変なことなんですよ
そこでお母さんたちがすごい気楽に学校の先生に文句言うでしょ
考えてください ああいう出来の悪い子供たち
全部まとめて一人の人がどうやって育てるかというと
でお母さんに自分の一人の子供の面倒も見きれないのに
なんで先生たちがね もうしっかり子供たちのことを見張っておかないんでしょうかとかね
もう怒鳴ったりするんだけど
やっぱりもう死ぬほど難しい仕事なんですよ
私は本当にこの幼稚園の保護者さんたちなんか見るとね
本当にもう悲しくてたまらないんですよ
なんて大変なことですかと
みんなむちゃくちゃあっち行ったり
こっち走ったり もうみんな前に来るのに一人だけ後ろに曲がってまた走ったりと
それで東京とか ちょっとそこどこかへ連れて行ったりする場合でも
あの道ででもきちんとガードしていかないと
もう大変な駅 駅になんかに連れて行った途端
いきなりあの列が壊れちゃって
まあもう大変な大騒ぎなんですね
ですから まあ子供の場合でもそういうことで
それだけじゃなくて 人間というのは大人になっても調教しなくちゃいけないんですよ
会社に入ったら会社の人を通してきちんと調教しておかないと
これ調教という言葉なんですよ
ですから それももう上司の方々にとっては大変な仕事なんですね
私にもいろいろ悩み事をみんな持ってきたことあるんだけどね
最近 会社で部下が二人ついてつけてくれたんだけど
全く変な二人で仕事はしたくないんだと
何か仕事行ったら これやらなくてもいいんだよと平気で言うんだと
どう言えばいいんでしょうか
どう育てればいいんでしょうかと
だから上から自分には全部仕事を教えてくれと頼まれてるし
でも若い人が入った人が
いや 自分がこういう仕事をするために来たんだから
そんな関係ないものをやりたくないんだよと平気で断ったりするんだよと
私だったら昔はそんなこと言わなかったんですよとかね
ですから 人を育てるということが大変なことなんですね
それどれぐらい大変かで
それで我々はおじいちゃんおばあちゃんになるでしょうね
そうするともう寝たきりになったり
病気になったり そうすると年下の人々が面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですね
その時も大変なんですよ
おじいちゃん これ食べてはいけませんよと言っても取って食べる
あるいはもう薬飲まなくちゃいけないのに
こういう薬 もうこれはいりませんよとかね
すごくまたわがままになっちゃうんですね
と わがままであっても
自分の息子やら娘やらね
面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないんですね
それでまたみんな文句を言うんですね
うちのおじいちゃんが本当に頑固者で
もうどうにも手に負えないんだよとかね
その場合は何でしょうかというと
この人を育てることっていうのはいかに大変かということなんですよ
そこをよく理解してほしいんですよ
我々も捨てたもんじゃないんですよ
ものすごい頑固なんですよ
誰か何か言っちゃうと
もうとにかくやりたくない
それに反対する わがままになる
それは八十歳になっても
九十歳になっても 死の一時間前でも同じなんです
言うことは聞かない それで人を悟りまで解脱するまで育てるということはもう大変な仕事
一番難しいこと それがお釈迦様
いとも簡単になさってしまいましたね
もう全く犯罪までする人でも
お釈迦様に会ってちょっと喋っただけで
もう犯罪もやめて もう真面目に出家して修行することになっちゃうんです
だからみんなびっくりするんですね
こんなにややこしい人間をね
なんであんなに会っただけで
喋っただけで育てるんでしょうかと
そういうことだから お釈迦様についてこのすごい話題になったんです
プリサダムサーラティという
これ日本訳は調教丈夫でしたっけ
調教丈夫というふうな
だからアヌッタラこの上ない最高な人を育てる能力あった人なんですね
それでお釈迦様に悪口も流れたんですよ
だってどんな人でもお釈迦様に会ったらもう大人しくなって
道徳的な人間になって立派になるんですね
そこで他の宗教の方々はお釈迦様は何かこのおまじないを持っているんだと
何か呪文的な能力を持っているんだと
マジシャンだと 言って人が来た途端そのマジックをかけちゃうんだと
かけたらみんなどうにもならなくなっちゃうんだよと
だから近寄るなよと 近寄った人はみんなもう終わりやと
そういうふうに悪口言われたんだけど
まあお釈迦様はそれに笑ってね
それは私悪口言ってたんだけど
結局私を褒めているんだと
だって私のところに来る人々は誰一人もみんな一緒に私の教えを聞いて
その道を歩むんだからと
次の言葉に行きます サッターデーマヌッサナ
サッターっていうのは先生であるということで
デーマヌッサナ人間と神々の先生であると
お釈迦様は全ての生命の先生なんです
いろんな話たくさんありますから
いろんな神々も夜になってくるとお釈迦様のところにあつまるんですね
他の人々も時々見たこともありましたし
なんかいろいろ心霊という軍大豪で言いましょうかね
いろんな心霊たちがいっぱい降りてきて
お釈迦様のところに周りにいるんですね
いたらお釈迦様はそういう人々にもよく説法をする
そういうことだから 人間だけではなくて神々の先生でもありましたと
それでブッドウ ブッダでありましたと
だから智慧の人で バガワーっていうのはものすごいこのそれにもいろいろ意味がたくさんありまして
バガワーっていうのは一般インドの言葉で言えば尊敬の人って意味なんですけど
パーリー語ではまた違う意味ね
煩悩をなくしたんだから
バッガティーティバガワーとかね
煩悩をなくしたんだからバガワーと言うんだよとかね
それから徳の高いというね
ものすごいもう最高の徳の高い人っていう意味でもバガワーと言うんだよと
いわゆる最高に尊敬に値する人って意味だと思いますね
一般インド語 インドの言葉から見れば
それで九人集まったんです
お釈迦様の話題 お釈迦様の話題になった九人の人
そのことをみんなもう喋ってるんですね
それで
そうイマンローカンサデーワカンサマーラカンサブラッマカンサッサマナブラームニんパジャンサデーワマヌッサンサヤンアビンニャーサッチカッターパウェーデーティ
それだけじゃない そのお釈迦様がイマンローカンこの世全部知っている知っていた上でお話ししているんだと
この世というのはサデーワカン神々サマーラカンマーラというこのもう悪魔ですけどね
神々よりは力強い強い天界があるんですね
そのマーラの世界 それもよく理解してサッブラッマカン梵天の世界
全部この人間より上の世界なんですね
神々の世界 マーラの世界
梵天の世界 それからサッサマナブラームニんパジャン
ボラモン人まとめている全ての人間の世界
なんでボラモン人の名前を入れたんですかというと
インドの世界ではボラモン人が一番上の人々だと決めていたんですね
ですから ボラモン人から始める全ての人間の世界はお釈迦様は知っていたんだと
パジャンサデーワマヌッサン
サヤンアヴィンニャー 自分で理解してサッチカッタ 経験までして全部自分の目で見たような感じで全部理解して経験してパヴェデーティ
みんなに教えてあげるんだと
いわゆるお釈迦様なら知らないことは何もないんだと
神のことであろうか 梵天のことであろうか
悪魔のことであろうか
もう全部知ってるんですよと
それもただ妄想も考えて知ってるんではなくて
自分で経験で知ってるんだよと
それでソダンマンデーセって彼が法を説くんですね
どんな
法というとアーディカリャーナ 説法の初めのところも大変素晴らしくてマッジェカリャーナ 説法の真ん中のところも大変素晴らしくてパリオーサーナカリャーナ
説法の終わりにも素晴らしく終了するんだという話ですね
いわゆる捨てるところは何もない
お釈迦様何をすごい簡単なことを教えたっても
大変素晴らしい言葉で
ものすごい難しいことを語っても大変素晴らしいことで
捨てることは何もないということですね
私たちの話とは大違いですけど
捨てることばっかしで覚えるところは何もないと
それはないんだよ お釈迦様の場合は
そこでサッタンサヴャンジャナ どんな言葉にもきちんとした意味があるんです
浮いてる言葉使わない
無駄な言葉を使わない
サッタンというのはミーニングフルという英語でいうこの大変意味があります
サヴャンジャナというのはこの言語の達人ということなんですね
いわゆるこの正しい言語を選ぶ
正しい言葉を選ぶ 私の日本語みたいに間違いだらけで訛りがあったりとか
そういうふうなもうはないんですね
例えば皆様にしても 日本語で自分の言葉なんですけど
喋ろうと思ったらそんな完璧には喋れないんですよ
正しい言葉を選ぶのは大変もう苦労しますよ
お釈迦様はそこの辺ではこの言葉のすごいプロで
何のことなく淡々とお話をする
きちんとぴったしの言葉を選んでお話をするんですね
まあそういうことで それでケーワラパリプンナンパリすっダンブラフマチャリアンパカーセティ お釈迦様は説法して何を言いますかというと
完全たるこの修行方法を教えてるんですね
このブラフマチャリアンというのはこの悟る道なんですね
悟るための悟りを開くための生き方をブラフマチャリアと言うんですね
ブラフマっていうのは尊いという意味で使っているんです
尊い生き方 完全たる尊い生き方を語っているんだと
そこでサードコーパナタタールーパアナンアラハタンダッサナンホーティティ タタールーパアナンそのようなアラハターナン アラハントたち
をに会った方がいいんじゃないかなと
みんなやっぱり我々も行って話した方がいいでしょう
こんなにすごい人ですよと
話題が広げていったんですね
うん そこでちょっと時間取りすぎちゃってね
まあ早く飛べるところは飛ばしてみます
次のセットに行きます
アタ
コトアタコトトゥッレコッティカトゥッレコッティカブラームナガハパティカイエナバイエナバガヴァーテーヌプサンカミンスプサンカミットアッペカッチェバガワン
タンアビワデット お釈迦様に礼をするんですね
頭を下げて お釈迦様にすごく
ものすごい丁寧に礼をして傍らに座る
もう一部の人々がバガワタサッディンサンモーディンソ
サンモーダニアンカタンサーラーニアンヴィーティサーレットアエカマンタンニシディンソ
もう一人の人々はお釈迦様と一緒にちょっとあの
なんていうかサンモーディンというのは喜ぶっていう意味なんですね
いわゆるちょっとお話をして
もう楽しい話をするというね
まあもしかするともうちょっとなんか面白い話をしたりとかね
まあちょっとした冗談でも言ったりとかね
まあちょっと笑ったりとかね
で 初めて会ったのでも
まあ我々は時々インドの文化ですから
まあ私はインド人ではないんだけど
初めて会った人のでも
いきなりなんとか冗談言ってもう笑ったりする癖はあるんですね
まあ時々機嫌がこちらもすごい明るいんだったら
もう初めて会った人なんですけど
もう何かもう言って もうこちらも笑って
向こうも笑って それから挨拶して仲良くなるという
そういうことなんで そこでお釈迦様にも何か何か一言喋って
で 何か 喜びの言葉を覚えておく
言葉を話しておいて 傍らに座ると
また ある人々はテーナアンジャリンパナメットアエカマンサンニシディンソ
お釈迦様のところにもうただ手を合わせながらアンジャリンというのは手を合わせることですね
お釈迦様の喋れません
来て お釈迦様の方に手を合わせながら座って待っていると
ある人々は礼だけして座る
ある人々がまた手を合わせながらじーっと待っているという感じなんですね
ある人々はいろいろお話をしたりとかね
もう笑い話したりとかね
お釈迦様はそれに何か言い返したりするし
そういうこともする ある人々は自分の名前と家族を言って報告するんですね
私は何々系の何々人ですよと
またもう一人 私はもう何々系の何々さんですよと
その名前を言って座ると
そこでまたあるグループは何も言わないで
ただみんなの後ろに来て
ただ黙って座っていると
そうやって人々というのはいろいろ性格の人々なんですね
その出来事をそちらに 2番目のセットで書いているんです
そこでみんな座って落ち着いたところで
お釈迦様がみんなに説法して納得させたんだと
それから説法するときはお釈迦様ダンミーアカタへサンダッセーシ
サンダッセーシっていうのは
このいろんな例えを出して
例を出して証明しながら喋るんです
証明ない話はお釈迦様はあまり言わないんですね
例えば悪いことするなよ
地獄に落ちるだよと言ったら
どうやって証明できますかね
証明できませんね お釈迦様は知ってるんだから
地獄の人も見えるようにすることができたどうか分かりませんだけど
それはあんまり証明的な話じゃないんですね
ですから ちゃんと証明出しながら話す
それはサンダッセーシということ
サマーデペーシということは
そういうことだから あなたもこういうことはしないように決めなさいよと
相手に約束させちゃうんですね
それからサムッテーゲーシ
人々にやる気を起こさせるんですね
応援するんです いいことをしましょうという方向へ
誰もいいことはあまりしたくないんで
普通は それでお釈迦様はものすごく応援するんですね
説法して サンパハンセーシっていうのは
みんなにこのやらずにいられないぐらい
この何て言いますか 気持ちをね
奮い立たせるというかね
気持ちを持ち上げてしまうんですね
だからお釈迦様を応援すると
応援された側もやっぱりもうバリバリでやりますよと
すごく明るくなってやる気になるんですね
それがサンパハンセーシっていうのは
だから決して仏教の道はみんな嫌々でやったわけじゃないんです
みんなすごく元気で明るくやりますよと
そんな話だったらという感じで
もう仏教を実践していたんですね
だからインドで仏教っていうのはすっごく早く広げてしまったんですね
脅しはないし もう何もないんで
もう信仰しなきゃ地獄に落ちるぞとかね
そんなこと何もない お釈迦堂々と言うんです
私のことでも疑いたければどうぞ疑ってみてくださいと
私が言ったことは本当かどうかも調べてみたらどうですかとかね
そういう調子でお話ししたんだから
みんなやっぱりこれやりましょうと
すごい教えではないかというふうに
もう元気で明るくて仏教を実践するようになったんです
だから出家した人々も
在家の方々も みんなものすごいもう活発なグループでしたから
ものすごいアクティブで
そこで自分がブッダの教えを信仰しているばかりで
人との固まって排他的になったこともないんですね
他の宗教のところにも堂々といって
みんなと話す みんなといろいろ議論までする
そうやって在家の信者さんでも
結局他の友達にも話したりして
違う宗教の友達であろうとも話したりして
そちらも悪いことからやめてもらったりして
すごい社会を明るく元気にしてしまったんですね
ですから そういうことで
インドの世界で仏教というのはすごい簡単に広げてしまっちゃって
ほとんど王様たちも仏教徒になってしまったし
バラモン人たちは自分の宗教あれにも関わらず
やっぱりどんどん仏教徒に入ってしまったんですね
だから仏教のアラハンたちの中でバラモン人の数が多いんです
それはお釈迦様に対してはすごいことなんですね
この 仏教徒たちが入っていただいたんだから
で これからこのよろしいですか？次のセットに行きます
テーナコーパナサメーナラッタパローナマクナプットータスミンエーワトゥッラコッティテーアッガクニカッサプットーティッサンパリッサーヤンニシンノー
ティッサンじゃなくてターサンでしょうと思いますけど
まあどっちでもいいです
[笑い]パリッサーヤンニシンノーホーティアタコーラッタパラスサクナプッタッセータダホーシヤターヤタークワハンバグアタダンマンデーシタンアージャナーニナイ
ダンシュカランアガーランアッジャヴァサターエーカンタパリプンナンエーカンタパリシッダンサンカリッサンカリッヒタンサンカリッヒタン
ブ
ラフマチャリアンチャリトゥンヤンヌーナハンケーサマッスンオーハーリットゥアカーサーヤニワッターニアッチャディットアガーラスマアナガーリャンパッバジェヤンティ
まあ一人だけいます そのグループの中にラッタパルという名前のある若者がいたんです
ラッタパルという その若者がこのトゥッラコッティテという村の一番上の家族の
財産的と家族としてだと思いますけど
一番たくさん財産 資産家でトップの家なんですね
その村の このトップの家の息子なんです
彼も座っていたんです
普通の若者でしたけどね
そこで彼にはこういう考え方が起きたんですね
私がこのお釈迦様の教えを理解した通りに考えてみるならば
このお釈迦様の道は 在家でいて
家でいて修行することは無理と
完璧に修行することは無理ですよと
まあそこそこで修行できるかもしれませんだけど
完璧に修行しようとしたら
これは在家でいては無理ですよと
エーカンタパリプンナンっていうのは
絶対的に完全に Absolute
perfectという Absolute
perfectつなげない英語ですけど
エーカンタっていうのはabsolutelyという意味なんですね
パリプンナンっていうのはperfect
完全 エーカンタパリシッダンというのは絶対的な清らかっていう
全く不純物がないように
完全な綺麗にという意味で
サンカリッヒタンというのはパーリ語でよく出てくる例えで
このあんまり意味がわからないんで
サンカっていうのはほら貝のことで
ほら貝を昔おそらく磨いて
いろんな模様も彫って作ったみたいですね
そういうほら貝 今もいっぱいありますけどね
お祭りなんかに使うほら貝
そうするともう全く白いです
色は そういう意味でね
何の結果もないように修行することはできませんと
出家しない限りは それで彼が決めるんです
ヤンヌーナアハン ケーサマッスンオーハーレットアカーサーヤニワッターナアッチャディットアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバジェヤンティ
ですから 私はもう髪の毛を剃って
髭も剃って この白い服を捨てて
黄色い服を着て出家しますと
と 彼がお釈迦様の話を聞きながらもう決めちゃったんです
自分一人で アタゴトゥッラコッティタブラアフマナガハパティカバグアタダンミャカタサンディスタマダサムティイッタ
まあちょっと飛びます
次のページに で ブラフマンたちが帰ってました
人々がみんな帰りました
説法終わってから この若者だけ残っているんですね
その若者残ってて お釈迦様に報告するんですね
お釈迦様の教えは完全に修行できませんと
出家しない限りは 完璧には
ですから私は出家しますと
お願いしますと ラベイヤーハンバンテーバゴトゥサンティケーパッバッジャン
お釈迦様のところに出家をいただきますと
ラベイヤンウパサンパダン
比丘戒ももうお願いいたしますとお願いするんです
少々飛ばして読みましたから
どうぞその場所を調べてください
ほんの少々ですから 次のところまた読みます
アヌンニャートーシ パナトゥアン ラッタパーラ マータピトゥーヒ アガースマ アナガーリャン パッバッジャヤーティ
でお釈迦様のところにこの若者が来て
出家をお願いしますと言ったら
お釈迦様がアヌンニャートーシ パナトゥアン ラッタパーラ マータピトゥーナン
あなた マータピトゥーヒ
母親と父親から許可もらってるんですかと
いわゆる両親に断りましたかと
いきなりお釈迦様は出家させません
若者の好き勝手に そこらもお釈迦様の道徳の世界なんですよ
この若者が一人 もう二十歳ぐらいだと思いますけど
でないとウパサンパダーできませんだからね
ですから それでもお釈迦様はあんたまだまだ結婚もしていないしね
だから親の管理下にいるんだよということで
こんな自由な好き勝手な行動できませんということで
ちゃんと親に断りなさいと
そこで彼がもう親は知りませんと言うんですね
そこでネコー ラッタパーラ タタハガタ アナヌンニャータ マータピトゥーヒ パッバジェイヤンティーティ
それでお釈迦様が言うんです
タタハガタというのは野良へい
野良へいですね 野良へいは両親が認めていないと出家させませんよと
そういうことだから 仏教の世界で親子関係はしっかり成り立っているんですよ
親不孝っていうのは仏教の世界では全くしないようになっているんです
お釈迦様さえも親は大事にしなさいよと
はっきりしているんです
ですから ちょっと十八歳になったんだからといってね
いい加減でわがままでやりたい放題やるということは
これはすごい道徳違反ですね
仏教から見れば さんざんお世話になったんだから
それから自分が何か一人前になって一人でやりたいというのは
それは悪くはないんだけど
一旦親に報告して 親の祝福もいただいてやるのは行儀だと
正しい生き方だと 結婚したければ
じゃあ私は好きだからその人と一緒になるぞと
そういうことじゃなくて
親に紹介して 親に認めてもらってから結婚するのはすごい仏教的なことで
世間では一般的なことなんですけど
そこら辺仏教は少々厳しいんですね
ですから 仏教の世界では小さい時からもう親を大事にするということにはなっているんです
次にソアハン バンデー タタガリサム ヤタハン マータピテロ アヌジャニッサンティ アガースマ アナガーリャン パッバッジャヤーティ
それで彼が じゃあ私は両親に許可を得るように話してみますということをするんですね
それで彼が家に帰って
お釈迦様に礼をして家に帰って両親に言うんです
アンマタータ ヤタヤタハン バグワというお願いするんだけど
母親の考え方はどうですかね
トアンコーターテラッテパーレアンマアカン
パーリ語を見ている方々は五十六ページの一番下のところ
で 四行目の最後の言葉から
トアンコーターテラッテパーレアンマアカンエーカプット
ラッタパーラ 君は私たち二人の一人息子だよ
ピヨーマナーポーも もうすごい大好きな一人息子だよと
スケーティトスカパリバト
ものすごくあなたをね
もう贅沢贅沢をさせて
すごい贅沢しながら育ちたんだと
ナタンターテラッテパーレカッサチドゥッカッサジャーナシ
君は苦しみということは一つも知らないんだと
ものすごくもう贅沢で育てちゃったんだから
苦しいっていうことは何なのかあんたわからないんだと
ですから イートンターテラッテパーレ
ラッタパーレよ ブンジャツピワチャパリチャーレーヒチャ
もう食べて飲んで遊んで
この家で生活しなさいと
ブンジャンとピワンとパリチャーレンとカーメンパリブンジャンとプンヤーニカロンとアビラマッス
あなたにはいっぱい財産があるんだから
もうよく遊んで よく気楽に生活しながら徳を積みなさいよと
ですから ナタンマヤンアヌジャーナマアガースマナガーレンパッバッジャーエ
我々は出家は認めませんと
一人息子だから マラネーナピテーマヤンアカーマカヴィーナバヴィッサーマ
私たちは死ぬ時でも嫌で死にますよと
君と別れるのは嫌ですよと
だから両親が自分が死ぬ時でも
やっぱり息子を捨てることが嫌で死ぬんだよということを言うんですね
どれぐらい息子のことを思っているかということなんです
キンパナマヤンタンジーワンタンアヌジャーニッサマアガーラスマナガーレンパッバジと
我々生きてるんだからね
あんたはもう家を離れて出て行くことをね
家を捨てることはもう認めるわけはできませんと
わけにいきませんと そこで二回目もお願いする
断られる 三回目にお願いする
断られる そこでこの五十七パーリ語の五十七ページの最後のところ
日本語になるとどこら辺ですか
そこで前家の息子ラッタパーラは両親を断食しちゃう
そうですね 断食するところ
アタコーラッタパーラオコラプットーマータマータピトゥスパッバッジャンアラバマーノタッテヴァアナンタラヒターヤブーミヤーニパッジー
それで彼がそのまま座り込んでハンスト始まるんですね
イッデーヴァメーマラナンバヴィッサティパッバッジャワーティ
私はこのままこのままで死ぬか出家するかどちらかにしますと言って座り込んでハンスト始まるんですよ
断食というよりは これストですよ
結構わがままでですね
そこでそれでも両親たちがものすごくもう言うは言うはもうできません
できませんと そこで それでこの人何も食べないし
座ってるんですね そこでも両親が頑張って頑張っても納得させようと
もう無駄でできなくなっちゃって
それで友達たちが来るんですね
一応まあ両親が友達たちを頼むんですよ
なんとかあの人を納得させてくださいということですからね
まあ普通の話でね でも友達たちもなかなか
もう何も話は聞いてくれない
そこら辺 大体もう簡単なところだからね
まあどうせ両親がもうハンスト始めたら
もう言って言って言って言って言って言って聞かない
彼が一言葉も喋れない
もうハンストでご飯も食べない
座り込んでいるんですね
そこでもう何の返事もしないんだから
両親たちが次の手段として
もうその人の友達に言ってお願いするんですね
何とかしてうちの息子をね
出家やめさせるように
行ってくださいと 友達たちもわかりますとと言って
ラッタパーラさんと話すんですよ
あんたはね もう出家っていうのは大変苦しいことでできないでしょう
両親にあんたしか一人息子でしょうしね
ですから この財産を守って
よく楽しく楽しく生活して
徳ぐらいね お布施ぐらいして
徳ぐらい積めばいいんじゃないかなと
言っても友達とも口は利かない
誰ととも そこでやっぱり友達っていうのは結構気持ちわかるんだからね
同じ年だからね 友達はもうわかったんです
この人はもう言うことはもう変えませんだからダメやと
そこでアタコーラッタパーラサコラプッタサハヤカーイエンラッタパーラサコラプッタサマーターピトロテーヌプサンカミンス
ウブサンカミントラッタパーラサコラプッタサマーターピトロエータダボーチュン
友達たちが両親に報告するんですね
アタコーラッタパーラサコラプッタサハヤカーイエンラッタパーラサコラプッタサマーターピトロテーヌプサンカミンス
ラッタパーラさんの友人たちが両親のところに行って
エータダボーチュンこういうことを言います
アマターター まあ父上
エーソーラッタパーラコラプットタッテーワアナンターイタブーミヤニパンノイデーメマラナンバビッティパッバッジャワーティ
ラッタパーラがもうこちらで死ぬか出家するか
もうどちらかに決めてあっち座ってるんだと
座り込んでいるんだと
サチェトゥンメラッタパーランコラプッタンナアヌジャニッサタアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバッジャヤタッテーワマラナンアーガミッサティ
あなた方はラッタパーラさんに出家を認めなきゃあの人は死にますよと
あんな調子では サチェパナトゥンメラッタパーランコラプッタンアヌジャニッサタアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバッジャヤパッバジタンピナンダッキッサタ
もしあなた方がラッタパーラさんに出家を認めたならば
出家してでも自分の息子いることは見えますよと
自分の息子が生きてるんだと
家には絶対帰ってこないんだけど
それでもどこかで元気でいるだろうというぐらいあるでしょうと
だからどっちにするんですかと
それで一応出家してもサチェラッタパーラコラプットナアビラミッサタアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバッジャヤタータッサアンニャーガティバビッサティ
例えばラッタパーラが出家する
出家して修行を始めたところで
なかなかもう気に入らなくなっちゃうと
あるいは苦労したことがないんだから
もう諦めたならばどうしますかと思いますかと
あなた方のうちに帰るでしょうと
また イデーワパッチャーガミッサティ
あなた方のところに戻ってくるでしょうにと
ですからアヌジャナータラッタパーランコラプッタンアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバッジャヤーティ
ですから認めてあげてくださいよと
認めて出家頑張っちゃったらこの人生きてるでしょうに
出家はダメだなと思っちゃったら
腰を上げてまた帰ってくるんだから
それでいいんじゃないんですかと
頑固に断っちゃったら死んでしまっちゃいますよと
そこで
両親がアヌジャナータータラッタパーランコラプッタンアガーラスマナガーリャンパッバッジャヤパッバジテーナチャパナマーターピトロウッダッセタッバーティ
そこで認認めるんですね
禅家ですというもんですか
禅家の息子ラッタパーラの友人たちは
禅家の息子ラッタパーラがいるところへ近づいていった
言って禅家の息子ラッタパーラにこう言った
サーユー 友ですね 友 ラッタパーラよ
起き上がるのだ 君はご両親によって家を捨てて出家することが認められた
ただし 出家すればご両親を一向に矜持しなければならないと
いわゆる親孝行しなさいということなんですね
出家したんだからといって親を忘れるなよと
だから友達もよくわかるんですね
親の気持ちは わかるんだけど
子供の気持ちもわかるし
ですから まあそういうふうに言ったんですね
うん なんかすごいこの間違ってる文章いっぱい入り込んでるんですね
この経典には このアッマハンとシャーマハン
どこどこかな それで彼がカッチャパーラ
クルプット ウッタヒットは立ち上がって
バランガヘットはまた体力も戻して
イエナバガはもうお釈迦様のところに行くんですね
行ってお釈迦様に報告します
アヌンニャーと 私はちゃんと許可もらいましたと
ですから 私は出家させてくださいと
でお釈迦様は彼を出家させるんですね
あれほどもうお金のある家なんです
一人で行って親は行かなかったんですね
まあ行けないでしょうしね
一人で出家してもらうんですね
アタコバガワアチュルーパサンパンネヤーヤスネラッタパーレアッダマースーパサンパンネトゥッラコッティテヤタハビラッターンビハリッットゥアー
サーワッティーエナサーワッティテーナチャーリカンパッカーメアヌフッベーナチャーリカンチャラマーノエーナサーワッティタダワサリ
お釈迦様が彼を出家させて
もう半年 半月 二週間ぐらいかな
その村にいて 早くもまた旅に出たんですね
サーワッティという西城の方へ旅に出たんですね
で 西城に泊まりました
西城というサーワッティで
アタコーヤースマラッタパーラエーコーウーパカットアッパマットアータアビパヒタットゥービハラントゥーノチラッセーヴィヤッサータハヤクルプットゥーサンマデ
ーヴァアガーラスマナジャレンパッバジャンティタダヌッタラムブラフマチャリーパーリヨーサナムディッテーワダンメーサヤンアビニャーサッチカッターウパサンパッジャヴィハーティ
さて 世尊は尊者ラッタパーラが入檀して間もなく
入檀して半月後 トゥンダコッティカで随員に仕まわれ
サーワッティという世に出られた 4
人に一行され サーワッティに入られた
そして世尊は そのサーワッティに近いジェータリーのアナータキンディカ荘院に住まわれた
後に尊者ラッタパーラは一人離れて住み
怠けることなく熱心に自ら励んだ
間もなく禅家の息子たちが正しく家を捨てて出家するという
かの無上の梵行の終結を現世において自らよく知り
あの辺に住持して住んだ
生まれは尽きた 梵行は完成された
なすべきことはなされた
もはやこの状態の他にはないと知った
そして尊者ラッタパーラは阿羅漢の一人になった
というところですね そのところでこのラッタパーラ尊者がもうサーワッティにジェータワナに入ったら
さっさと修行に励んで悟るんですよ
完全に いわゆる修行を完成するんですね
そのパーリ語の説明なんですけど
何のために出家するかという目的がありまして
その目的に達したんだと
それからお釈迦様がおっしゃったものはディッテーワダンメー
目の前でというか 自分の体できちんと体験して悟り開く
キーナージャーティ それからこの輪廻転生なくなります
ブシタンブラフマチャリアン
修行はもう完成しました
カタンカラニヤン なすべきことは全部なし終えた
ナーバランイッタッターヤ
これからやることは何もないという状態になりますと
いわゆるこれからは輪廻転生することも
苦しむことも何もないという状態になりましたと
で イッタッターヤティアッバニャーシ
よくわかりましたと 自分でも
もう終わりましたと で
それでラッタパーラ 今までラッタパーラさんだけでしたけど
これからラッタパーラ阿羅漢になりますからね
ラッタパーラも一人の阿羅漢としてもう知られてしまいましたと
完成になった人として
アタ
コーヤースマラッタパーラエーナバガワーテーナパサンカンパサンカミッターバガワンタンアビワディットゥーアイエカマンタンニシリーエカマンタンニシンノーコー
ヤースマラッタパーローバガワンタンエタダボウッチャイッチャマハンバンテーマーターピテローウッダッセトゥンサチーマンバガワーヌジャーナティーティ
で もうラッタパーラさんも本当によくできた息子で
ちゃんと出家してきちんと修行して
悟り開いてしまう 悟を開いたらお釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様に挨拶をして礼をして
もしお釈迦様が許可するならば
許すならば 私が両親に会って
両親にももうなんとか教授をしたいんだと
両親の面倒を見てあげたいんだと
そういう約束でしたから
友達と で アタコーバガヴァーヤスマトーラッタパーラッサチェータソーチェートーパリタッカムマナセーマナサーカーセ
お釈迦様がラッタパーラさんの心を読んでみたんですね
ラッタパーラの心を心によって熟知ですか
熟知され 推移された で
お釈迦様がもうラッタパーラが本当にもう出家してまだそんな時間経ってないんですよ
1週間でサーワッテに出ていて
そこでサッサッサッと修行してもう悟ってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから もう家に行って両親に会ってもよろしいでしょうかと
ということをちょっと心配だから
お釈迦様も それで心を見たところで
もう悟っているんですね
完全に お釈迦様はアバッボーコーラッタパーラオクルプットーシッカンパッチャッカエヒーナーヤワッティトゥンです
もうこの人はもうまた在家に戻って欲に溺れるということはありえないんだと
シッテヤッサダーネトンラッタパーラカーランマンニャス
あなたまあ行くと行きたいと思うならば
もう今いいんじゃないんでしょうかと
今適切な時期ではないんでしょうかと言うんですね
アタ
コーアヤスマラッタパーラウッタヤサナバグワンタンアビワディットワパダッキナンカッターセーナーサナンサマーセッターパッタジーヴァラマーダーエーナトゥッラ
コッティタンテーナチャーリカンパッカーミーアヌプッベーナチャーリカンチャラマーナエーナトゥッラコッティタンタダワサリー
それでラッタパーラサンがもう全部まあ片付いて
もう出ていく 出て行ってトゥッラコッティタット自分の村に行く
村に行ってどこかに泊まりましたね
タトラすだんあやスマラッタパーラトゥッラコッティテヴィーラティランニョーコーラッブヤッサニガーチーリ
そのクルラテクル国の王様がこの狩りをする森があるんですね
狩りといっても鹿ですけどね
鹿狩りをするんですね
その森に行って そこで泊まりましたと
もう家がないんだからね
自分には それでラッタパーラサンがご先祖
衣を着てトゥッラコッティタ町に入って托鉢します
出来事 心得 言うこと 彼がこの村に入る
村に入っても自分の家には行けない
行けないで王様が狩りに行って鹿を狩る
鹿を鹿狩りに行ったらその村森があって
その中に泊まって そこは私の
を含めて 夜そこで寝て
朝起きて托鉢に出るんです
だから托鉢に行く途中で自分の家に行きたいんですね
だから 何の招待なしに好き勝手に在家の人の家に行かないんですね
ですから もうたとえ自分の両親であろうとも
在家の世界でということにするんですね
ですから 両親が来てくださいと言ったら行ってもいいんですけどね
でも托鉢の場合は どんな家にも行ってご飯をいただくことはできます
ですから ラッタパーラ尊者が本当にもう帰りし者の通りに
じゃあこれで明日托鉢するに行くんだと言って
ついでに親の顔も見るんだと
サカニウェーサナンテーヌプサンカミ托鉢に行く行く途中で自分の家に行ったんですね
行ったらどういうことになりましたか
テーナコーパナサメーナアヤスマドラッタパーラッサピターマッジマーヤドワラサーラーヤウッリカーペーティ
これは日本語でわかりません
百七十八ページですね
三行目ですね ちょうどその時
尊者ラッタパーラの父親は中央の門楼で髪を整えさせていた
尊者ラッタパーラの父親は尊者ラッタパーラが遠くから来るのを見てこう言った
はい で まあこれすごい大きな家ですからね
で マッジマードワラサーラーヤっていうのは
この中央の門のところにホールがあって
そのホールで髪の髪の毛をね
整えてたんですね 頭洗っていたでしょうね
そこで遠くからラッタパーラお坊さんが来るのを見たんですね
見てディスワーナエータダウォーチャ
すごい怒ってるんです
見たところで イメーヒムンダケーヒサマナケーヒアムマカンエーカプットーピヨーマナーポー
パッバージトーと このもうハゲですね
そうです このハゲ頭のね
もう沙門たちが私の大好きな一人息子を連れて行ったんだと
で もうラッタパーラさんが自分の父親の家で何も頂かなかったんですね
ラッタパーラとは気づかなかった
気づかなかったんですね
お布施も得ず 拒絶も得ず
その代わりに罵倒のみを得たのであったと
かなり言われたんですね
だから直接顔も偉い人々だから
かなり遠くでね 家の玄関の方に立ってるんだから
本人に見えないんですね
あまり その代わりにものすごく怒鳴りつける
その言葉だけは聞こえる
追い出す必要もないんですから
かなり遠いところで待っているんだから
この人 真ん中のね ホールでいるし
一応怒鳴りつけているんだからね
テーナコーパナサメーナアヤスマドラッタパーラッサニャーティダーシー
アービドーシカンクンマサンチャッデートゥカーマーホーティ
その時 尊者ラッタパーラの親族の女性奴隷がですね
昨夜の残飯を捨てようとしていた
そこで尊者ラッタパーラはその親族の女性奴隷にこう言った 「
そなた もしそれが捨てられてしまうのであれば
私のこの鉢へ入れていただきたい」と
クンマサンっていうのは
まあご飯か この 小麦粉で作った何か食べ物なんですね
ですから冷蔵庫はないんだからね
腐っちゃうんですよ ですから捨てるんです
捨てようと家の外に持っていくんですね
持っていくとラッタパーラ尊者が 「
じゃあ君がそれ捨てるんだったら
私の鉢に入れてください」と
すると尊者ラッタパーラの親族の女性奴隷は
その昨夜の麦菓子を尊者ラッタパーラの鉢に入れながら
両手両足 そして声の特徴を捉えた
そこでソンジャラッタパーラ
マソリカル準備できますと
そのラッタパーラさん
また父ちゃん  上司に言うんですよ
ヤッディへアイエージャーネイヤース
アイエプットーラッタパーローアヌッパットーティ
えーと あ ゴシジンサマ
これあの百七十九ページの初め頃
ご主人様 どうかお尻になってくださいませ
ゼンケーの息子ラッタパーラが来ているようですと
で まあちょうどその時
ソンジャラッタパーラはそのサッキャの麦菓子をある
何でしたっけ？ ある垣根に寄りかかって食べていた
なんかわかりません ん？ 何かでした
うん うん どこかに腰をかけてね
食べましたと
アッタコーアヤスマントーラッタパーラッサピターイエナアヤスマラッタパーローテーナパサンカンバサンカンミットアヤスマンダラッタパーランイエタドート
息子来てるんだと聞いたら
まあ父親がまた行くんですね
言って こう言うんです
アッティナーマタートラッタパーラ
アービドーシカンクンマーサンパリブンジッシー
ナヌタートラッタパーラサカンゲーハンガンタッパント
で そこで「なんであんたね
この腐ってるもん食べてるの？自分の家ではないかとね
家に入りなさいと 家に入った
入るべきではないか」と
そこで息子の答え クトーノーガハパティアンマカンゲーハンアガーラスマアナガーリアンパッバジタン
で ガハパティっていうのは
この まあただご主人というふうな呼び方なんですけどね
で 「我々には家を捨てた
捨てて出家した人には自分の家っていうものはないんですよ」と
アナガーラマヤンガハパティ 「
我々の家がない」 アガマンマコーテーガハパティゲーハン 「
まあ私は家を出て行ったんだ」と
タッタネーバダーナンアラッタマナパッチャッカーナンアンニャダットゥアッコーサンエーバアラッタッマハティ
だけど父親と呼ばないんですよ
あの ガハパティっていうのは
妻家の人っていうか ちょっと敬語
敬語ですけどね まあご主人と訳してますからね
まあ主人でもよろしいし
で これはまあ「私には家がないんだ」と 「
一応家には行ってはみたんだけど
もう何もいただかなかったし
まあ罵倒だけはいただきましたけど」と
エーヒタートラッタパーラガランガミッサーマ
まあ父親 それにもかかわらず
もう もう息子として呼ぶんですね
もうラッタパーラもうそんなこと言わないで家に行き帰りましょうと
アランガハパティカタメアッジャバッタキッチャン
そこでまたまあ夫人を私まあ結構です
私は今日は食事をいただきましたと
それで父親ももうどうにもわからなくなっちゃって
テーネヒタアッタラッタパーラアディワーセーシスワータナーヤバッタン
だったら明日のご飯に家に来てくださいと紹介する
まあそれで家に入ることはできますからね
アデ
ィワーセーシクーワーヤスマラッタパーラワトゥンヒーバーウェーナアタコーヤスマラッタパーラッサピターヤーヤスマトゥラッタパーラッサアディワサナンアディワサ
ナンウィディットワーエーナサカンニウェーサナンテーナプサンガンプサンカミットワーマハンタンヒランニャスワンニャッサプンジャンカーラーペットワーキランジェ
ーヒパティッチャーデットワーヤーヤスマトゥラッタパーラッサトゥラーナドゥーティーケアーマンテーシエータトゥンメーワドゥケーエーナアランカレーナアランカタ
トゥッベーラッタパーラッサコルプッタッサピアーホータマナパテーナアランカレーナアランカロターティ
アタコーヤーヤスマトゥラッタパーラッサピタータッサラッティアッチェーナサティニウェーサネーパニタンカ
まあもうストーリーですからね
父親は何をするんですかというと
自分の家の財産を全部もうまとめるんですね
そこら辺は日本語で読んで早く終わりにしましょうね
読みますか  はい お願いします
そこでソンジャラッタパーラの父親はでよろしいですか
はいはい  ソンジャラッタパーラの同意を知り
沈黙によって同意したから同意を知り
自分の住居へ近づいていった
一と金貨と黄金の大きな山を作らせ
諸々の布で覆わせ ソンジャラッタパーラのかつての妻たちを呼び寄せ
告げて言った さあ 妻たちよ
そなたたちはかつて装身具を持って飾り
全家の者からラッタパーラに可愛がられ
愛されたように その装身具を持って飾りなさいと
さて ソンジャラッタパーラの父親はその夜が明けると
自分の住居で最上の好食の飲食を用意させた
そしてソンジャラッタパーラに時間を告げた
お前ラッタパーラよ 食事が整ったと
そこでソンジャラッタパーラは午前時に着衣し
鉢と衣をたもち 自分の父親の住居へ近づいていった
言って用意された座に座った
するとソンジャラッタパーラの父親は
その金貨と黄金の山を開き
ソンジャラッタパーラにこう言った
お前ラッタパーラよ これはお前の母の母の財だ
父のものと祖父のものとは別だ
お前ラッタパーラは富を享受することも功徳を積むこともできる
さあ お前ラッタパーラは賢明として富を享受し
功徳を積みなさいと もうちょっとですね
はい  主人よ もしあなたが私の言葉に従われるのであれば
この黄金と金貨の山を車に乗せて運び出し
ガンジス川の流れの中に沈めてください
なぜかと言いますと 主人よ
それによってあなたに憂い
悲しみ 苦しみ 愁い 悩みが生じるからですと
はい まあ結構です あの
お前ラッタパーラと変化しているんですけど
そういうふうな言葉ではタータっていうのはもうすごいかわいい言葉なんで
パーリ語でね ものすごいかわいい呼び名で
うーん まあ適切な日本語の言葉がないね
父親にもタータと呼んでましたか
ん？ 父親のこともタータと呼んでましたか
その場合はもう その場合タータというのは父ということで
同じ言葉 文字なんですけど
例えばお坊ちゃん このお嬢ちゃんと言われる子供を呼ぶでしょ
名前知らない場合はね
そのような感じの言葉なんですね
小さな女の子ならこのお嬢ちゃん
もう坊やとかね そういうふうな
このもう可愛いという感情の言葉なんです
だからまあ父親はもしかするとラッタパーラ坊やとずっと呼んでいたかもしれませんね
ですから その呼び名は変えないんですよ
まあ出家者とも やっぱり両親っていうのはね
やっぱりあの お坊さんの名前で呼びたくないんですよ
まあそれはまあ親の気持ちだからね
大体呼ぶことを避けるんです
で 出家者名前まで まあこの場合名前変わらなかったんだけど
我々の場合名前も変わっちゃうでしょうし
だから父親も母親もやっぱり自分の息子だからね
もう前から呼んだ同じ言葉で呼びたいんですね
それを呼ぶのは失礼だから
ほとんど私も家に行ったって
昔でももうほとんど黙っていると
両親はもう黙ってて もう呼ぶことだけやめて
他のいろんなことでもう会話したり
もういろいろことをなんか知らないことでも聞いたら
もう一生懸命もう顔真っ赤にして説明してくれたりとはしますけどね
呼びたい場合は兄弟にちょっと呼んでくださいと
まあそこら辺やっぱり気持ちがね
まあお坊さんの名前では呼ばないんですね
で 兄弟に呼んです  はい
ですから この場合でも
それはごく普通のね 人間の愛情のことだからね
タータラッタパーラとずっと呼んでいて
出家してもタータラッタパーラと
日本語の適切な言葉はないでしょうね
否定的な言葉ではないんです
そこでお父さんが頑張っちゃうんですね
財産全部ではなくて 親方の財産かな
母親のものだけ出してね
これもほんのちょっとだけですよと
これぐらいあるのにね
ちょっと遊んでくださいと
なんか奥さんたちもいたみたいですね
何人か そこで何のことなくガッタパーラさんだが
もし父親が私言うことを聞くならばね
父親とは呼んでないんですけどね
もし夫人が私言うことを聞くならば
それは全部持って川に捨てなさいよと
なぜならば あなたはかなりそういうことで苦しみますよと
次にガッタパーラさんの奥さんたちも
からかっちゃうんですね
あなた どのような天女たちと遊びたくて天国に生まれ変わってね
どんなような天女たちと遊びたくて修行しているんですかと
いわゆる彼女たちはやっぱり性的な話を出したいんですね
気持ちを引き起こして戻ってもらおうと
言ったら その女の子たちを彼が『』
バギニという言葉で自分の奥さんたちを呼ぶんですね
バギニっていうのは妹って意味なんですね
じゃあこちらどんな訳でした？妹たちよ
我々天女のために修行をしているのではありません
それ妹たちよと呼ばれちゃったら
みんなもうおかしくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆる私たちの文化では
女の人を妹と呼んじゃうと
それでも全く兄弟関係であって
それ以上の異性的な付き合いっていうのは消えちゃうんですよ
この一言葉だけででもね
例えば知らない女の人でも
どこかで男の人に会って何か助けてほしいというのもちょっと心配でしょうしね
でもその男の人は妹 なんでしょうかと聞いちゃうと
もうすぐもうそこで実はこういうこと
ちょっともう助けてくださいといったら
もうそれで安心するんですね
あの一言葉で 警戒はしないんですね
ですから 妹と呼ばれちゃったら
もう自分たちをもう異性として認めてないということになっちゃうんですね
もう兄弟で見ているんだと
彼女たちがたわらちゃいますね
アタコーアヤスマラッタパローピタランエタデウォタサチェガハパディボージャナンダータッバンデエタマアノービヘッテーターティ
そこでまあラッタパールサンジャがね
まあまあ主人何か食べ物をあげると思うならばあげなさいよと
私はもうなんていうか
困らせないでくださいと
ブンジャターデラッタパーラニッティタンバッタンと
やっぱり父親はまあいいですよと言って
まあ食事用意していますから食べなさいよと
それでご飯食べてアッタコーアヤスマラッタパローブッターヴィオーニータパーニティタコーワイマーガーターバシ
ご飯食べてすぐ立つんですよ
すぐ帰ろうと 立ったまんまで説法するんです
で これはこのまあ他のところでお釈迦様がおっしゃった説法なんですけどね
それでまあ全部偈で入ってます
まあ本当は まあそうか
パッ
サチッタカタンビンバンアルカーヤンサモッシタンアータラバフサンカッパヤッサナッティドゥアンティティパッサチッタカタンルーパンマニナークンデレーナチェア
ッティッタンチェーナオーナンダンサハワッテーヒソーバティアラッタカタパダームカンチュンナカマッティカンアランバラッサモーハヤナチャパーラガヴェーシノー
アッタパーダカタケーサーネッタアンジャナマッキタアランバラッサモーハヤノーチャパーラガヴェーシノーアンジャニワーナワーチッッタープーティカーヨーアラン
カトーアランバラッサモーハヤノーチャパーラガヴェーシノーオーダヒーミガウォーパーサンナーサーダーワーカランミゴーブッダーニワパンガッチャーマカンダンテーミガバンダケー
それ注しちゃうと随分時間は取りますけど
パッサチッタカタンビンバン
パッサっていうのは見よ
見なさいよと チッタカタンっていうのは綺麗に綺麗にわさわさと綺麗にしているビンバン
この形を見なさいよと
で 形っていうのは体のことなんですね
この体見なさい もう父親に言うんですよ
この体見なさいと わさわさ強引に綺麗にしているこの体を
もしかすると自分の女の人々のことを言ってるかもしれませんね
女の人も父親が呼んだんだから
もうありったけの宝石やら全部もうお化粧やらね
つけておきなさいよと
ですから この真理の知ってる人の立場から見れば
まあこの女性たちがわさわさと自分を綺麗に見せてるんですね
ですから 美しさっていうのは強引なんですね
この強引に綺麗にしているこの美しさを見なさいよと
本当はアルカーヤンサモッシタン
何でした？キスを？キスをそなえ集まっている
ページの最後の短いところですね
キスをそなえ集まっている
で キス口ですよ 体にあるのは
キス口ここの座ると言うんですね
だからそこからはもう汚い気持ち悪いものばっかり出るんですね
キス口っていうのは両目
そこからもういろいろ涙やら目の目やにとかね
出たりするし で 鼻二つ
鼻の穴二つあります それで四つになりますけどね
それからもう鼻水やらね
汚いものばっかり流れて
ですからキス口やと 汚いものを
キスが戸だったら膿とか出るでしょうに
同じく だから同じくキス口やと
口からも出るのはそういうものでしょうし
耳二つありますね それからも出るのはそういうもので
下にまた穴二つあるでしょうに
決してどこからでも綺麗なもう香りのあるものとかね
香水とかは出るわけじゃないんですね
汚れた気持ち悪いものばっかり
この九つ穴から出ているんですね
そこを強引に移動してかぶせて隠して
綺麗に飾っているだけではないかと
だから人間というのは幻覚の世界で喜んでるんですね
実際 事実を見ようとはしないんですね
とにかく綺麗に飾っておこう
飾っておこうとかね 隠しておこう
隠す 事実隠そうという生き方なんですね
仏教は事実隠そうとはしない
日本の葬式にしたってもね
遺体はまあものすごい綺麗に飾るでしょうね
時々人から話聞くときはね
本当にすっごい笑顔で寝たような感じでいたんだよ
仏様とか言って本人喜んで私は何やと思っちゃいますよ
何も本人の親戚が亡くなったんだからね
もう最近のそういう出来事ありましたけどね
本当に立派で寝たような優しい顔でいたんだよと
てません 何やと思っちゃう
だから何でしょうかというと
あるいはきちんとそう見えるように遺体をお化粧するんですよ
それでアメリカだったらものすごい技術もっと進んでるんですね
もう好き勝手に化粧できるんだから
体に悪い色でも塗れますでしょうね
死んじゃったんだから
ですから 遺体のお化粧っていうのは
もう生きている人のお化粧よりも抜群にいいように作っちゃうんです
作って綺麗に見せておく
もう結局遺体は遺体でしょうにね
あんまり綺麗なものだとはね
人間は感情的には思わないものですね
それで我々の生き方というのは
事実を隠して その隠したことが事実だと勘違いする世界なんですね
だから死んだ人の顔がね
葬儀屋さんが綺麗に見えるように作ったんだから
なんと素晴らしいですか
この方は寝ているように安らかな顔ですねと勝手に喜ぶ
だが 死ぬところはそんな安らかな顔じゃなくて
もしかすると翔太もさんじゃなくて
まあお嫁さんにも怒鳴ったりとかね
お医者さんにも怒鳴ったりして
もう散々苦労して死んだかもしれませんし
ですから 死ぬ瞬間の心で生まれ変わっちゃいますからね
遺体は綺麗に出来上がったんだからといってね
ちゃんと成仏しているんだというのは
それを勘違いであってね
気休めなんですね だからなんで嘘で気休めで生きてるんですか？それすごい危険だよというのが仏教の立場なんですね
事実を見ましょうと 見たら別になんのことなく落ち着いていられるんだと
そこでこの傷口あるんだと
アー туランバフサンカッタ
アー туランというのはもう病気ばっかりですよと
この体は 本当のところ我々はこの病気ではないと勘違いしてるんだけど
どんな人間も二十四時間何かが病気があるんですよ
今調子どうですか？と聞いたら何か文句あると思いますよ
足が痛いとかね 肩がちょっと痛いとかね
何か必ずあるんです だから人にどうですか
元気ですかと聞いても
私は正直時々冗談で正直に答えようとするんですよ
これはもうすごい失敗ですけど
正直に答えたらいつでも病気だからね
いつでも何か体の調子
何か悪い それは自分が今年だから自分の
じゃあ若い時どうですか？って
やっぱりその時もそうでしたからね
元気だと思って走り回っちゃいますけど
どこかにも石に足がこけたりするし
これで痛くても一時間
一時間ぐらい痛いとかね
もう木登りなんかしたり
滑ったりしちゃうと そこら辺全部傷だらけで
それでまたもう二週間傷でいなくちゃいけないし
もう体いっぱい傷 傷跡
跡 跡もう見ちゃうとね
もう絵を描いたような感じですけど
だからもう小さく もうガキで遊んでた時でも
もうそこら中傷だらけで
まあ日本では今はね もう完全ガードしてみんな遊んでるんだから
それほど傷がないんだけど
それ見て私は男だったらやっぱり傷いっぱいないと何かちょっと何かちょっと足らないという感じもしますけどね
ですから やっぱりちっちゃい時から死ぬ時まで
いつでも何かが病気があるんですよ
一つの病気が止まったら
我々は病気だ 病気だ 大変だというだけのことで
それで病院に連れて行っちゃうんですね
例えばお腹が痛くなって
それ止まっちゃうんですね
止まっちゃうとお腹が悪いと思っちゃうんですよ
胸が痛くなって止まっちゃうと
あ これ大変だと レントゲン撮らなくちゃいけないんだと思うだけで
病気が止まらないで あっちこっち歩き回るんだったら
元気ですよと平気で言うんです
元気じゃないんですよ
健康な瞬間ないんです
この体には 体そのものが病気で成り立ってるんです
それが事実なんです 健康だ
健康だっていうのはちょっとごまかしなんですよ
そうやってごまかして
その幻覚作って それが正しいと言って頑張っちゃうんですね
だから本当に全て水の泡で
猿で水を汲むような感じなんですね
だから常に体が病気だよと
例えば足が痛くなる まあすぐ立ったら消えますね
それで病気だと思わないんですよ
足が痛くなったんだけど
その病気が止まってしまうと
それで病院に行かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
我々病気というのは この常にある病気が一箇所に止まった時だけ
ですから いつでも病気だよと
うーんと バフサンカッパンというのは思いが多くと書いてますね
体についてはいつでもあれやこれやと我々はいろんなことをもう考えてるでしょうに
他の勉強する暇がないんですね
人間には体のことばっかり考えてるんだから
24時間も ですから 我々の思考もかなり体使ってるんですよ
ヤッサナシドゥアンティッティ
ヤッサナティドゥアンティッティ
その体には決して永遠ということがないんだと
こっち何も遜色もないと書いてますけど
ドゥアンっていうのは体は永遠にあることはないし
安定している状態でもないんだと
体は決して安定しているわけでもないし
永遠でもない 次の偈に行きます
身を飾られた形態よ 宝石
耳輪ですか によっている
骨は皮膚に覆われて衣服によって輝いている
足は うん 赤粉で うん 彩られている
うん それは愚者の惑わしえても
敵させと で 次にパッサチッタカタンビンバン
この強引に飾っているこの形態を見なさいよと
どういうふうに体 マニナ
宝石と耳輪やら色々つけてつけて飾っているのは強引だからね
じゃあ見ようと笑ってるんですね
このお坊さんが それでいくら飾ったっても
これは骨と皮膚でしょうとね
骨 骸骨を皮膚でもう覆っているだけのことで気持ち悪い
そういう風に考えちゃうと
それに宝石を強引につけたりしてね
きれいにしてるんだと
そこでこの骨と皮膚だから気持ち悪いんだから
また衣服をね 巻いておいて
これ隠しておいて 宝石もつけたりと
それで足に赤い粉を塗ると
これはインドのお化粧方法で
足が赤い方がすごいセクシーだと思ってるんですね
ですから この中国と中国は昔はね
足が小さい方がというと
あの纏足というんでしたっけ
そういうくだらないシステムあったでしょうし
インドではそうはないんだけども
足は真っ赤に塗っておくんです
で あの赤い粉をね 塗って
だから天女たちの美しさを説明する時でも
あの何でしたっけ 鳩の足のような色ですよと
と書くんです それ何の色かとわからなくて
私も鳩の足を見たら赤いんです
ピンク色ですよ すごい綺麗ですよ
他の鳥の足っていうのはすごいもう老人の足みたいな
あまり綺麗じゃないんです
それに鳩の足はすごい綺麗です
それでも足にそうやって塗って
顔には白い色を塗って
そんなことはもう愚か者にはいいんだけど
もう簡単に騙されますけどもね
解脱をする人にとってはこの騙しは効かないんだよと
そこでアッチャパーダカタケーサ
髪の毛はなんでしたっけ？蜂の便に余れ
あの女の人々のおしゃれを説明してるんですよ
で 次何でしたっけ  目にはアンジャナが
ネッタアンジャナマッキタ
目にはアンジャナというのはものすごい黒い特別なものであって
あれは薬なんです インドではアンジャナというものは
お化粧用に使いますけど
すごい高価なもので ものすごい高価なものでしたみたいですね
ほんの軽く目に塗っておくんです
目のまぶたのところに
塗っておくと 西洋的なあれよりは結構綺麗に見えますけど
すごい薄くすっごく薄く塗るんですね
それで目が薬の力ですっごく輝くようになっちゃうんです
目がスッスッスッとなってしまって
それで目の血管なんか消えちゃって
輝いちゃうんですね ですから
アンジャナというのは
これはもう贅沢のものすごい金持ちの人にしか使うことはできないんです
一般の人にはできません
すごい高いんです そんなものをおろかものを騙すためにはいいんですけど
真理知る人にとっては解脱目指す人には意味がないんだと
アンジャナニチェナワチッタプーティカヤアランカト
次は何でしたっけ？目には
とにかくの綺麗な新壺
新しい壺を見て人の体は飾られている
新壺って何ですかね  新しい
アンジャニワナワチッタプーティカヤアランカト
まあ一応壺に例えるんですね
本当はあんまり綺麗な壺ではなくて
糞というかね 便を入れている便を運ぶ壺なんですね
で 例えば家でね 大便小便しちゃうと
昔は土で素焼きの土で作ってる壺を使うんですね
それをそのまま捨てるんであって
また洗って使うっていうことをしないんですね
ですから それは一応どうせ中に入れるものは気持ち悪いものだから
外に何かちょっといろいろ絵を描いてペンキを塗って綺麗に見えるようにする
それでそれに便をして蓋をしておく
そうするともう何も見えません
綺麗に見える それが体ですよと
外の飾りはね ただ綺麗に見せかけてるだけですよと
そんなものはね これ綺麗な壺でしょう？って言ったら
馬鹿者だったらそうですね
綺麗ですねと じゃあ持って行ってくださいって言っちゃうと大変なことになる
うん で 最後にオオダヒミゲオオパーサン
そこは日本語でどうでしたっけ？ 罠を仕掛けても鹿は網にかからなかった
そうそうそう ナサダ ワカラミゴ
まあ漁師は一応網をつけたんだけど
鹿はもう引っかからなかったと
それはお父さんやったことに言ってるんですよ
自分を引っかかるために
こんなすごい無明の幻覚の苦しみの世界に引っかかって殺してやるぞと思って
お父さんが一応網を罠を引っ掛けたんだけど
もう鹿はもう賢くてもう引っかからなかったと
ブットアニワパンガッチャーム
餌だけは食べちゃったんだと
だから罠に餌をつけているんだから
だからバカな鹿がそちらへんいっぱい食べ物あるんだから
それ食べればいいでしょうね
ちょっと余計に揃ってる餌を食べない方がいいんですね
だって自分であっちこっち行って食べられる葉っぱ探して探して苦労して食べた方が安全でしょうしね
それで罠かける場合はいっぱい餌をね
美味しい葉っぱいっぱい取ってきて
綺麗に並んでおいて そこでバカな鹿がそれをパクパクと食べながら言ったらすぐ引っかかってしまっちゃう
それで殺されちゃうんですね
ですから この鹿は賢くて
それはもう食べないんだということで
この場合は餌を食べちゃったんです
餌を食べて逃げたんだと
ガッチャームカンダンテーニゲバンダテー
で 鹿を捕まえを捕まえろと思った人が泣きながら泣いてるんだけど
鹿は逃げていくんだと
と言ったのは この息子を止まってもらおうと思ったお父さんがいろいろ罠を仕掛けたんだけど
また再び父親が泣きながら息子が出ていくんだよと
で 立ったまんまでその偈を唱えて
サクターパール尊者が森に戻って
木の下に座って瞑想禅定に入りましたと
それで午後もっと大事な経典の大事なところは後から出ますけどね
一旦時間も飛んでしまいましたね
中断いたしましょう ありがとうございました